what happens to you it cannot be the
thoughts the thoughts
it cannot be
the emotions the feelings that you
experience
so what is the nature of i
what does that work
who you truly are
underneath
all the circumstances
[Music]
[Music]
the feelings that you experience
so what is the nature of an eye
what does it mean
louder with crowder is brought to you in
part by.com
head over to the shop support the fight
and buy some cool threads
it's the tits pajamas.com
[Music]
hey everyone welcome to climate changers
my name is alfonso blue and i'm alicia
green today we're going to be talking
about the rising temperatures of our
planet earth rising temperatures
but it's not even that hot out i'm even
wearing this jacket
okay bigot sure you don't want to be at
a trump rally right now
just kidding we all know alicia loves
science but temperature can be deceiving
so let's take you through it
[Music]
did you know that according to our very
own scientists at nasa that our planet's
temperature has been increasing by 0.13
degrees fahrenheit per decade
that's almost 0.015 degrees fahrenheit
per year
i do love the planet and science
but
that just doesn't sound like a lot to me
i thought you might say that so that's
why i brought these burgers to
demonstrate i made our little friend
here let's call him
donald to demonstrate the effects of
earth's temperature on a scale that's
easy to visualize
say alicia how does little dawn look
well
i guess he looks alright to me he does
now but let's check back in a few
minutes
[Music]
how about now alicia
wow
he looks really hot
i guess something that you don't think
is a big deal right in the moment can
cook you alive later on exactly now
you're getting it
[Music]
tune in next week to see what you the
average viewer can do about it
[Music]
hey everyone alicia green here again you
may have noticed that sometimes during
the show i might pretend to question
climate change but i can assure you that
is for educational effect only in real
life i trust the science one hundred
percent
it may be all right to have a few
questions about climate change once in a
while especially if you're younger but
if you know someone that repeatedly
rejects scientific fact no matter what
take down their name address and any
social media information you can find if
they're an adult or your parent make
sure to get a copy of their photo id
then call this number
or send it to this email address
thanks guys let's keep changing the
planet
[Music]
[Music]
stranger
speedy
[Music]
bring it i'm going to see ocean levels
rising oh as well look not really
we'll get through that but i hope to see
open ocean levels rising here we're
doing the entire
show the entire show today is on climate
change really climate claims rather and
by the way that's the promo code enter
climate claims yeah at lotterycredit.com
mug club you get 10 dollars off
and i do ask that everyone out here use
the hashtag today yes on social media
hashtag climate claims let me explain to
you uh what we're going to be doing okay
i know a lot of you are going to say hey
oh a second you're not a scientist
that's absolutely true
and neither are you
no that's how you but what's the third
law of thermodynamics if you didn't
answer instantly why do you think that
the ice caps are melting you are exactly
guilty of what you accuse the right of
being so this is not about going through
scientific consensus this is about going
through the most publicized claims
that have existed from 1970 all the way
up to today in every reputable journal
or news outlet that has existed all the
news that's fit to print the claims that
you believed for a very very long time
to point out the claims that are being
made now so we will have predictions
that were made whether uh those
predictions came true or not and the
updated prediction because there's
always been an updated well you you have
to pivot every once in a while have it
so
uh also let me let you know that uh this
is a live show monday through thursday
10 am eastern that's right if you miss
it here on youtube you say where is this
show uh or if we get removed for uh
accurate information
uh just go over to rumble or mug club
ten dollars off right now before i move
on here uh it's time for me to introduce
gerald how are you i'm well sir how are
you it's nice and cool in here it feels
it's like climate change is not
happening in this room yeah well you
know what that's what we call anecdotal
listen i know it's a real thing of
course yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah quarter black garrett i hear that
climate change affects
disenfranchised distance it does
minority is the most very affected yeah
i can tell the hawaiian shirt
it's like a biracial dicky green leaf
and uh unfortunately dave is not here
today because he came down with the the
big bird flu um in his place however and
keep in mind he's going to be at the uh
cotillion in wichita kansas oh he's
still left earlier thursday so he left
early to make that date you guys want to
see it if you're in wichita kansas yes
or anywhere else close to wichita kansas
um so we actually have uh in his place
greta thunberg's uh
older sister brother uh how are you
i'm fine
okay ahoy and what are you are you
greta's older brother older sister yes
okay
i i i was supposed to be the first
anti-climate change bloomberg but then
gretchen came along she began to develop
early and caught everyone's attention
and i was left to be nothing oh no and
you were in the attic and mother never
came for you that mother never comes for
me she never calls oh those thunbergs in
the attic all my family members are very
attractive except for me yeah wow
well i guess it's a relative term i've
seen your parents right
yes they're very doable mm-hmm yeah yeah
oh boy
okay
uh oh double dare you okay that was my
catchphrase yes i get it i understand it
doubled there you added she had a little
i added
i dare you to stop ruining the planets
even great another brave well you know
what challenge not accepted in another
brave display of activism by the way
your little uh sister yeah uh greta
thunberg protested
i haven't seen this clip so i guess this
is a watch and react yeah the cop26
summit here we go this cop 26
is so far just like the previous cops
and that has led us nowhere they have
led us nowhere exploitation no more blah
blah blah no more whatever the [ __ ]
they're doing inside
whoa
language wow
sister oh man i hate her yeah well
listen
sibling you're gonna learn to love her
she has undeniable sex appeal yeah
it's okay because she's 18 now why do
people cheer when a child cusses uh it's
a weird thing not a child anymore no no
i know an 18 year old fine yeah i think
he's a grown close to 90 year old yeah
right whatever what i mean or as
muhammad would refer to her pastor prime
yeah
like by a long shot yeah oh no
oh come on you old man
it's not my fault your ovaries are dust
bunnies
so
um
by the way let me ask you this
uh what's the mo before we move on here
because we have like all references are
available at our clerics so much we have
like 150 or something like that today
absurd what's the most ridiculous
climate prediction that you have heard
what were you taught in school
uh i remember one obviously i was taught
that the polar bears were going to be
extinct thank god yeah yeah i don't
really care you mean the killing
machines yeah the ones who kill baby
seals and hunt humans i've never done
one yeah
so oh no haven't seen yukon cornelius
lately have you no his well you will
find his lower intestines soon
about the alaska
i believe there's more polar bears yes i
do well hey dave you got really deep
there well he told he told me i couldn't
do the character the whole time i
couldn't yeah i needed to have him for a
little bit be too annoying it's going to
come in and out all right
prettershop.com if you want to support
the show before i move on here
everything is climate change this week
climate claims is the hashtag
yesterday pete uh butt giggs um
husband
i guess yes casting so pete is it
chaston chasing something i don't know
sure i don't know so no one's wearing a
chest and belt anytime soon
it's defect it's defective so tweeted
this at dennis prager who was trending
because of comments about aids he
tweeted uh aids patients died because
people feared simply touching them would
lead to infection families abandoned
their own children to be buried in
unmarked graves let us know where we can
send the books dennis god forbid you
read one uh and i was i want to be
claire was happy to correct uh his
understanding uh no aids patients died
from having unprotected anal sex with
strangers and intravenous drug use just
to be clear i know that by the way this
is just from the left it doesn't you
can't have this both ways what aids aids
patients died because people didn't
want to touch them that just means they
die and have less friends are you trying
to tell me that doctors
get it off me get it off and for granted
they're treating people with ebola and
even if they were buried in unmarked
graves which by the way i don't know if
you can substantiate that that just
seems vindictive for no reason at that
point it doesn't they're already dead do
you know why so many died because of
anthony fauci's policies for example the
same kind of myths that you're
perpetuating that people with aids could
transmit it to people uh through
airborne uh mechanisms he did say that
he did my yeah my house is haunted
though by aids ghosts it was it was
built on an unmarked cemetery of aids
bodies really oh no yeah so all
just it's it's just coughing instead of
booze well and also just at repulsion
they just go
boobs
catch aids come on the walls bleed
that's the scariest yeah i know well you
know what red rum so look let's move on
i want to use the jumping off point here
uh former uh president barack obama did
i say former president president barack
obama
he was in glasgow um and he showed up to
lecture
all of the uh all of the uh all of the
the riff raff
river you and me
on uh the time is flanking he uh wanted
to lecture all of us on climate change
so i'm guessing he flew southwest dave
right presumably directly from his 12
million dollar martha vineyards
waterfront manchester united yes yes
which was built by solar panels and
sunshine farts you say it's on the water
on the waterfront
you would put a house there if you
thought the rising levels
it's an interesting investment well you
don't you can't read his mind so he
spent a large portion of his speech
crapping on donald trump
republicans taking no responsibility and
of course tooting his own horn this
happened yesterday here is former i mean
president barack obama back in the
united states of course
some of our progress stalled when
my successor decided to unilaterally
pull out of the paris agreement
i wasn't real happy about that
the determination
of our state and local governments
along with the regulations and
investment that might believe
already put in place allowed our country
to keep moving forward despite hostility
from
the white house the power to do even
more to fight climate change during my
time in office if i'd had a stable
congressional majority that was willing
and eager to republicans not my fault
it's yours and for the bulk of my
presidency i didn't have that majority
both of us have been understand in large
part by the fact that one
of our two major parties
has decided not only to sit on the
sidelines but express active hostility
toward climate science
and make climate change a partisan issue
sit on the sidelines like you should at
pick up games of basketball how does it
feel to know that you're the first black
president who would get dusted by sarah
palin on the courts wow
we're playing street rules this is just
no no no no none of it is my fault it's
all republicans and donald trump who
came in and was hostile maybe it's
because you removed all the t's from the
keyboard you prick like let's just be
clear about how petty barack obama was
he blamed bush when he came in and now
he's blaming donald trump on the way out
let's be really clear about something
the biggest reason that greenhouse
emissions okay uh have steadily
decreased is because of natural gas now
i know what you're saying i heard
fracking is bad for the environment i'm
not saying that fracking is carbon
neutral however fracking and using our
own natural gas is significantly better
for the environment than purchasing oil
from countries overseas who don't have
epa standards and shipping them
across the ocean on tankers where by the
way spills happen every single year that
make the bp oil spill look like child's
play or gensake however you prefer to
refer to it
by the way if i remember correctly
barack obama had a majority in both
houses and his first 100 days he chose
instead of saving the planet
to push obama no no no no not not not
now you're confused i i don't think i am
and uh uh racist
but
i just you know i know a lot of people
don't like them but it is interesting to
see a president that can talk as opposed
to one that has a closed head injury and
underwear filled with applesauce
now the problem the primary problem with
joe biden and
and i've told him this i'm not talking
out of turn is
he poops
constantly
just non-stop non-stop the old man poops
come on man the parachutes too smells my
smells kid smells my kids and they think
it's weird and gross and then and then
he poops
so
the pairs of cords don't do anything
okay china the world's greatest polluter
yeah right make pollution great make
pollution great again
they've increased carbon output even
though they sign on to the paris
agreement oh oh yeah we'll get right on
that paris agreement but you have our
word
they bought it
no trust me 2019 after leaving the paris
agreement for contrast the united states
reduced emissions by nearly three
percent the most of any
uh major country and i want to be clear
about something here
this is you're referred to as a climate
denier if let's say you acknowledge
climate change let's say you acknowledge
that maybe humans are contributing to
climate change let's say you acknowledge
that that could have some negative
results
let's assume you've gone along the trail
if you just don't believe that the paris
accord will do anything you're a denier
well look
china signed on and got worse america
pulled out and got better than any other
country come on guys this is about don't
be led by the nose and that's why we
want to go through all these predictions
this is going to be a longer show
19 i think starts at 70 through today
all references are available but first
before we move on to that uh obama uh
former president obama uh did quite a
bit of fear-mongering
among uh i just said in mongering i'm
hungry
it's mongering he's a fishmonger uh
among what there's not left that's
there's no more in the ocean yes all the
starfish are dead because peter keeps
trying to screw them
[Music]
don't even don't even try and don't even
try and go to a child's party with all
the balloon not nuts
it's a smorgasbord for pete but
i don't know what's happening uh barack
obama did his share of fear-mongering uh
with the crowd here you go and the
consequences of not moving fast enough
are becoming more apparent all the
time last month a study found that 85 of
the global population has experienced
weather events that were more severe
because of climate change
stronger storms longer heat waves more
intense flooding crippling droughts
parts of the world are becoming more
dangerous to live in kenya triggering
new migration patterns and worsening
conflict around the globe
it's one of the reasons why
the u.s pentagon and other u.s agencies
have said that climate change poses a
national security threat for the u.s and
for everyone else
okay
let me be really clear here
weather related deaths have decreased
drastically over time now i know people
say that's a gross simplification
because we've gotten more effective
methods blah blah blah blah sure but the
fact remains he wants to scare you and
he wants you to think that everybody's
going to die while he lives on
oceanfront property uh 12 million
dollars in martha's vineyard just to be
clear he's not living in tucson michael
right he also said that these are caused
by climate change while presenting zero
evidence that weather is caused by
climate change becoming more severe
not the
the problem with you gerald is you're
not a scientist
oh are you scientists obama but i can
read did you just hear the predictions
that he made you just heard them right
everybody here heard them i just want to
be clear uh
let's will anyone ever call him on it
this is the issue people had no problem
they've had it on a morphe as a morphine
drip on cnn yeah on msnbc when they say
hey you're not a scientist it means you
shut up neither is barack obama neither
is joe biden and certainly not greta
thunderberg so dare you let's go into
this week's mega theme show today
climate claims
[Music]
use a hashtag climate claims and it
gives you ten dollars off what are you
so concerned no i'm happy those bears
look like they're gonna be a little
warmer yeah and it's freaking cold there
yeah they sweep some chimneys i mean
come on
make a little extra pocket change it's
nice to warm things up a little bit you
know well i want them around i like uggs
yeah you ever see a polar bear floating
off on an ice cap like a piece of ice
it's the saddest thing i ever saw oh my
gosh you know what happens to polar
bears if uh they have to swim further
they turn over and they float because
they have hollow hair folks
yeah they couldn't really wanted to
well i think you're wrong okay
i think they're del they're not
delicious
there you go
i ate a polar bear once
it's because i had to respect the native
american the inuits culture we use them
to light lamps
yes
they were the lamps that burned well
into the night
all right so look it's not any secret
that the only way you are controlled
with climate predictions the only way
that you get to the green new deal or
the cop26 or where i went to the cancun
climate summit they supported one child
policy ted turner to thunderous applause
the only way you get this far down the
trail of course is through
fear mongering but you don't have to
take our word for it droughts are
intensifying our oceans are acidifying
with methane plumes rising up from the
ocean
yeah we are seeing extreme weather
events and the west antarctic and
greenland ice sheets melting at
unprecedented rates how about these
decades ahead of scientific projections
none of this is rhetoric
and none of it is hysteria it is all
rhetoric
by the end of this sentence he could
take a break from having sex with
anything he wants another four to eight
degrees what i'm saying is the planets
on
fire
there are a lot of things we could do to
put it out are any of them free
no of course not nothing's free you
idiots grow up aren't you a socialist
anymore i didn't mind explaining
photosynthesis to you when you were 12
but you're adults now and this is an
actual crisis got it this is about our
constituents and all of our lives iowa
nebraska broad swaths swaths of the
midwest are drowning right now under
water
farms towns that will never be recovered
and never come back and we're here and
and people are more concerned about
helping oil companies than helping their
own families i don't think so i don't
think so and for more most of your lives
if you're in that generation you've been
bombarded
with warnings about what the future will
look like if you don't address climate
change
no farms in iowa silly [ __ ] okay
let me go through you mean flooding that
seasonally happens and has forever yeah
yeah yeah yeah and iowa
crying out loud unbelievable yeah well
let's i guess we're gonna have to find
another place to do the straw poll
where is that happening
i've been all over the country i've
never i've seen some flooding everywhere
well there's one place it's called new
orleans because building that far below
sea level is stupid well how many times
are you going to keep rebuilding it i
know yeah yeah habitat for humanity well
you just want to just why don't you just
have them on retainer would you want to
just move north a little bit yeah i got
a pamphlet for you move yeah there you
go there you go it's a problem
what's gonna what are you gonna wash
away in new orleans that anybody needs i
don't know do you think someday like
after climate change there's gonna be
some post-apocalyptic world where
somebody finds a missing city of
atlantis and it's just someone's titty
beads like
what are these or they used for this
wonderful culture and this was used in
ritual sacrifice hold up a red solo cup
these beads sent the girls gone wild guy
to jail yes oh wow and we believe they
used to worship the god of street
bourbon
so
let's go through some predictions here
and you guys can jump in whenever uh
we're gonna start in 1943.
wow prediction 1943 yep the u.s was
going to reach peak oil remember that
term for i know uh the the
out there you may not know this because
i've kind of shied away from it now
because i just don't really want to talk
about it but uh let me just give you
just some sources references and then
we'll have all the references at the
worldcrater.com they warned about peak
oil in 1943 bradford evening star 1956
corpus christi times 1977 us department
of energy organization act 1980 the
syracuse post standard 1996 nobel
laureate richard smalley 2007 government
accountability office 2021 the
international enter energy agency let's
be let's also be clear about this when
they talk about peak oil in 2018 i was
either 18 or 19 the united states
was a net exporter of oil for the first
time and god knows how long it might
have been the first time ever i know
it's the first time on modern record but
we went back oh well yeah no because the
environment's better off when we're
begging a saudi prince to like to light
our homes and lugging it across the you
know the pacific and then absolutely but
let me give you this an updated
prediction we're going to reach peak oil
in 2040. oh yeah this one's for real
kicking that tin can on down the road i
mean if you just keep changing it
eventually you're right i mean yeah i'm
wrong the other times with this that's
only eight more years if my math is
correct
yes absolutely correct
what do you remember learning about peak
oil in high school i i've i've heard the
term so i just want to go clarify
remember while you were on did you were
you saying that each one of those was a
new set date for peak oil no that was
when the predictions were made in
official
i mean publications so so i'm just
saying it's a prediction they've
constantly been making and then
sometimes they'll say well it's gonna be
five years from now uh it's gonna be uh
it's gonna be three years from now like
al gore made his prediction i think that
the uh we'll get to it later i think
yeah there was like the antarctic ice
sheet was going to be gone by 2013 and
then he sort of stopped it was like ah
or i meant or you know a general
timeline you know what uh you know what
prophets who uh predicted stuff that
didn't come true in the name of god and
the old testament had to deal with they
stuck a glass rod up their pee hole and
smashed it with a hammer a little bit
that's a chinese a little bit worse
lordy dude look it up i'm just saying
yeah yeah yeah worse than that you just
keep predicting it for 50 years yeah
just keep running that thing all right
let me go to the next one since uh dave
doesn't remember peak oil no you don't
need to be sorry i remember hearing that
yeah it's peak oil means we're gonna
basically gonna run out of oil i also
remember use reduce recycle yet you just
watch it get thrown into the dump with
everything else yeah yeah around the
corner they just put it all together hey
what about george clooney advertising
for nespresso without a recycling
campaign really how many people do you
think put it in that little burlap sack
and carry it back to the shitty mall
where they purchased it oh this is a
this is alleged but i know somebody who
used to be his limo driver and said he's
the biggest piece of crap ever oh yeah
he's just a horrible human being well
you know that's that's what happened
that's why he does the head thing it's
his inner [ __ ] trying to get out he's
like contain it
so
1967 here's another prediction
prediction number two i guess we'll go
through these in a list and you guys can
comment uh as you're watching live uh or
sorry as you're watching after saliva
which of these most stands out to you uh
a dire famine was forecasted to be the
worst and most disastrous ever by 1975.
so you mind this was made in 1967 they
were saying by 1970. did that have five
this is from the un washington post the
atlantic the evening standard uh
no oh oh well that's good i guess that
it didn't happen or were they
implementing it oh john kerry made it in
2015. wapo did it again in 2017 and you
ended it again in 2020 um i don't
remember those the deadliest famine in
history by the way the truth was in
china from 59 to 61 had nothing to do
with climate change um had more to do
with uh you know kami prix do you
realize uh warming the temperatures up
just a little bit actually produces more
food it makes people less likely to
starve reduces food costs around the
world no no no now if you're going to
bring your your non-scientific [ __ ]
in here we don't want to hear it uh it's
it's actually fast you can walk your
sorry ass on i'm back to kenya where
i've never been but there's study after
study
shut it down yeah but no seriously
studies show this you should really look
at it yeah warming one degree or two is
uh actually good for crops you know
we'll get to that in a little bit
there's so many predictions today
it's a theme
uh by the way updated prediction now
they've predicted it they predicted to
get in 2021 the u.n really yeah yeah
yeah you have that overlay eye i think
you won't know the vitamin d kill covid
i have no idea but wait in 2021 that's
only got like a month and a half or so
left yeah it'll happen i mean no no they
predicted it again in 2021 oh they're
learning to be a little bit more uh
abstract with their numbers they got to
get a little more nostradamus yeah let
these things
maybe happen i see an unattended crutch
by a fire
what
all right what does that mean thanks ted
turner
so here's another prediction uh in 1969
and again the point here is not
what about are you a scientist no no
these were predictions that everybody
believed you just saw no one has a
problem with the fact that leonardo
dicaprio is not only not a scientist but
incapable of developing a romantic
relationship with anyone who looks like
they're older than 15.
it's a preference i guess
if you had a man bun like that would you
you know look i don't blame him i mean i
don't blame leo dicaprio he's saving the
environment by buying 35 priuses yes yes
for his 19 homes yeah whatever the rare
earth
that he can find and he gives every
nine-year-old he dates a blood diamond
so my point is yeah
he ate a bear
i don't know how but you know he carries
it well as long as this is number three
in 1969 population biologist dr elrick
said in 20 years everyone would
disappear
this is not a joke in a cloud of blue
steam this was a biologist this is what
he wrote we must realize that unless we
are extremely lucky unless we are
extremely lucky
everybody will disappear in a cloud of
blue steam in 20 years now what i know
i'm doing the theme here of you know
their claim prediction and the truth
this is one of those it's so uh it's so
out there it's like when a guy just
starts windmill punching in a boxing
match i don't even know how to handle
that it's so dumb as far as i know
this hasn't happened but i guess
let's check in with the office see how
they're doing
[Music]
[Music]
i spoke too soon it said i love you
brendan
where'd he go yeah where'd he go he's in
the air she should have should have been
drinking his milk
mother says all right let's uh pretty
sure we're gonna ditch the wig in the
glasses because at some point
i cannot so are you speaking this one's
uh pretty tough to find a comparable
prediction like an updated version okay
i think they sort of decided to
just
lean away from the
blue smoke
the thanos snap what is it green smoke
now or something uh well the closest
thing i could find is a report ahead of
the glasgow summit claims that 10 men 10
million people will die by 2030. ah
okay why how will they i don't know
maybe there will be some kind of super
aids i have no idea maybe there's like a
giant travis scott concert whatever
there's going to be violence on the
african continent uh continent like like
barack obama
i'm like oh jeez that's never happened
before he's stabbing people with a
fentanyl yeah with a super fat is that
what happened with travis scott
who knows but they're saying it's like a
super possibly a super fence no
because fentanyl wasn't strong enough
what if you're like i just i can't be
carrying these rice grain sized amounts
of fat no what am i a pack mule yeah
it's like it's like a cereal commercial
for kids where it's like there was a
problem at the fentanyl factory what now
it's whoops all fat now it's mini fit
now oh no yeah there's so much fentanyl
you won't you'll die before you finish
chewing it
guys this is a climate change this is
the first time we've seen the effects of
climate change directly impacted yeah
concert and i have plenty of evidence if
you just read a book okay yeah
i don't know how to read yeah well you
know what we all have to bear i read
braille because i prefer to touch my
words
well your words touch me so i guess it
comes from a circle there
rail books
i don't know who i am anymore
i can't hear the clap
here's a prediction prediction number
four in 1970 again the hashtag is
climate claims hey look look look i'm
not going to continue the show until we
see climate claims trending somewhere i
don't care where
like 20 000 you hit like on youtube last
week just share this right now out there
it's how many likes do we have with the
climate claims i don't care about the
likes i want people to get this out
there because everyone out there is
going to say well this isn't look this
is the most referenced
uh episodic that i can think of on this
topic yeah none of these are coming from
you know uh q
anon.net.tv these are coming from new
york times washington post timing
dicaprio
try to tweet it out as serious as
possible but also make it insulting yeah
just try to go a little under the radar
if you happen to include uh a picture of
your genitals well look no no no no no
no
this isn't australia doing the i'm at
home shot for the covet stuff what you
could go this is a swampy mess thanks to
global warming that's funny that was
jeffrey's tuban's nickname in college
really yes swampy mess
i thought it was old faithful
oh no
all right 1907 here's prediction number
four
they made the prediction that this is a
california newspaper redlands daily
predicted there would be a food
rationing in 64 and water rationing by
1980 and this was echoed across
the country uh the truth is in 1980
there was actually not only enough food
for the modern diet system to be put in
place the first national nutritional
guidelines were actually issued but
here's the thing we do have an updated
prediction okay now that was 1970 was it
1970 i have to i have to be using these
notes here today i think i want to make
sure that you guys don't crucify me if
i'm off by a year or a month because i
know that that invalidates everything
don't kid yourself it's going to happen
anyways yes
but now the new prediction is by 2035 60
percent of our meat will have to be lab
grown why i don't give away i don't care
if cal's fart i watched selma hayake
grasshoppers once that was fun
hasn't the colonel been doing that for
years
he's like you are my eyeless babies
you're born without feathers what are
the secret herbs and spices crickets
what i do to them is the spice oh
what their pain they can speak
their screams are the extra spice
so here is something a prediction in
1970 another one now i want to be really
clear because you're going to say were
you showing this documentary well this
documentary was released it was very
popular however this is a sentiment that
was echoed
for many many years throughout the 70s
and there was scientific consensus in
the 70s but i wanted to provide uh
visual aids sorry we're not what we're
done with the chase butt gig thing
visual uh assistance there you go uh
leonard nimoy
here he is
talking about how there was gonna be a
new ice age by the year 2000 here what
scientists are telling us now is that
the threat of an ice age is not as
remote as they once thought
during the lifetime of our grandchildren
arctic cold and perpetual snow could
turn most of the inhabitable portions of
our planet into a polar desert the
brutal buffalo winter might become
common all over the united states
climate experts believe the next ice age
according to recent evidence it could
come sooner than anyone had
at expected stations in the far north
temperatures have been dropping for 30
years you know frozen health
long free of summer ice are now blocked
year-round
according to some climatologists within
a lifetime we might be living in the
next ice age
what you couldn't you couldn't hire kirk
too busy preparing a space launch listen
second string needs some help yeah well
you know what hopefully it dry freezes
those ears
fixed
well we're food rationing so next is
saying nanu nanu buddy
right
stupid spock
so just to be clear i wanted to show you
that because that was released and it
was a fear among you know fear-mongering
of course but but it's bad ice is bad in
that one yeah well isis yeah that one
yeah
it's almost like they understood that
frozen tundra is worse for crops but let
me really quickly hit this this was
widely accepted science this was
washington post 1971 the white house
1974 guardian in 1974 time magazine
1974. the world could be as little as 50
or 60 years away from a disastrous new
ice age is what the washington post said
time said telltale signs are everywhere
when climatologist george j kuklov
columbia university i mean these are
everywhere and here's something else too
this is something that you're told today
now i'm not saying that because they
were wrong about
all of it before
but that means they can't be right about
anything today right but the argument
that they throw out 97 consensus
immediately dismiss it it's a [ __ ]
argument okay i've told you about this
before you can go back and watch that
segment however
this is not the first time
that they've made this argument this is
important because now people say well
there might have been one or two i just
gave you every major publication
throughout the 1970s and not only that
but these major publications were saying
that anyone who denied the idea of a
coming ice age were denying what what
scientific consensus this is from new
york times all the [ __ ] that's fit
to smear
saying climatologists can predict what
temperature averages and extremes to
expect over the next 10 20 30 years
they're predicting greater fluctuations
and a cooling trend for the northern
hemisphere and they uh they invoked the
uh the
rhetoric of scientific consensus this
was in 1976. it seems like the same
arguments they're using today but tell
me one of the the warmest uh years on
record 2000
no
1930s 30. you'd have to go back to the
yeah i know but it was uh the fourteenth
foreign record was two thousand that's
what i have right here
i just find that funny because it was
warmer before an inconvenient truth and
then yeah moderately cooler afterwards
exactly well no no that was the pause
the great pause yeah yeah he was like
the guy who timed all of his stock
betting on on ask jeeves
he couldn't have picked a worse time al
gore bought american airlines on
september 10th did you
oh really bad idea well really it was
actually spirit oh i thought that uh
you know paying for your carry-on
luggage was innovative
united 93.
i sit on the board at apple
i don't even know how to work the thing
but
either way one time i got my wiener
caught in it because i thought it was a
swedish
i don't know what happened they said you
could do that on the internet i didn't
know it wasn't directly into the floppy
drive anyway that's not important more
money please more money please so
man bear pig there was no ice age in
2000 it was the 14th warmest year on
record uh
oh there wasn't no there wasn't oh what
a surprise nimoy you have failed me
i like how in the 70s are like who can
we get that's a real scientist spock
plays one on tv
did you graduate high school yeah no no
no no
i don't trust worthy put you on the
cover of time there'll be none the wiser
i've been in space though do you have a
haircut that's uh on a statue in a
chinese restaurant yes people will
assume that someone who's that weird
looking is clearly intelligent they have
to be that's the whole life budget
theory
so he does have an intelligence about
him yeah he's an actor so we know he's
not right yes exactly right he's a liar
for a living here's an updated
prediction a mini ice age now you may
not know this could hit the earth by
2030. so they haven't totally abandoned
the ice age argument well they but they
said many ice yeah i don't know what
that means apparently open to
interpretation it's just a little chilly
buffalo is going to get cold again it's
like an ice age with less storage well
well it it roughly goes from november to
february right yeah it's minutes
interesting these are just general
guidelines just no i'm not a scientist
don't mean anything here's a night
here's another prediction in 1970.
number six life magazine claimed that
people would have to wear gas masks for
pollution by the year 1985. oh they were
kind of right it's just not for
pollution right yeah well you know what
here's what's funny is the updated
prediction now coven masks will cause
record levels of waste in the ocean oh
no oh no a hermit crab is going to be
wearing someone's face diaper as a shell
but they won't get covered they won't so
we've noticed there's a natural immunity
to covet from hermit crabs
they're all wearing masks very compliant
crustaceans
somalis works under water i don't know
what i'm always getting all these sea
cows are very well protected from covet
they just wear amy schumer's mask
just a manatee and a mass as black lives
matter
i need the lizzo version please
it's trying to light everything on fire
but it can it's water think about this
for a second all the dispel because the
disposable mass those are the only ones
that work yeah right your reusable
cotton masks your reusable poly blend
mask disgusting they don't work at all
but let's let's think about this for a
second every time i go to a restaurant
now i have to drink from a wooden straw
so that everything tastes like a number
two pencil because that god forbid there
was some sea tortoise that might be
chewing on my bubble tea straw but now
you're like by the way uh let's just
everyone disposable masks and if you
want it to work you have to wear a new
mask every single time you touch a mask
well this is according to dr anthony
fauci by the way let's anybody get mad
at us i don't know what happened to
don't touch your face no no let's don't
touch your face
the paper straws are awful they're the
worst seriously you get you get the
paper in your mouth yeah yep part way
you would say what are you supposed to
do with this part who sips i'm going to
a cocktail bar with my wife and her
friends so it's 18 a drink and you say
oh i guess give me your twist on a
gimlet with a little bit of a habanero
and it tastes like kindling wow wow good
do you have anything in the dura flame
flavor
you drink a well yeah you drink liquor
through straw i don't well they'd give
you straws
you do if you're an alcoholic and your
mouth don't work yep oh well and you got
a hole in your neck i guess you got me
yeah well you talking about al gore okay
so here's another prediction in 1989
rising sea levels would drown countries
by the years too
here i guess i don't even know it's like
how do you fact-check this have any have
any countries drown is there are there
any countries that haven't learned how
to swim yet do we have any atlantis's
out there yeah yeah yeah is it are the
keys wearing floaties no okay i think
they're still well they've updated the
prediction now it's florida will be
drowned by uh 2060 from the guardian now
they just keep yeah just push the date
back a little bit right so by 2060. so
they said it would be gone by now but
now by 2060 you can be sure they're
they're not going to be able to take any
more bloodlines i i have a speech
prepared for this oh uh really yes well
it's less a speech and more a music
video but it's important oh
the world is dying unless i can save it
[Music]
stand
via the thunderbird
i was lightning and then dunbar
thumb bug fear the thunder
lightning and the thunderbird number
kids were laughing in my glasses
while polar bears are dying by the
masses look at you who you think you are
driving that big shiny car do you want
me are you thirsty do you want to see
what's in me oh okay
okay why did you stop that before the
sexy part well you know what i know
you're 18 now but i can't see anymore
i'm bored still can't put a price on
life experience i'm gonna do it here
then no stop it no no no
why am i cutting back to it i can't
daddy what is it daddy's been dirty it
says back off man i'm a scientist oh
okay
from a movie because i'm going to turn
back into dave now because this wig is
itchy all right okay let's cut away from
it yeah please let him take off the wig
and the damn jacket
done i didn't know that he was going to
be doing this this morning i was like
look you can't do this whole show you
got to give me a heads up when we did
the show as you know we had bernie
sanders hosting the show and donald
trump
guys just so you know
there you are only going to talk to
bernie or donald trump all right look
you said do something for climate change
and we thought a greta thundberg music
video was the only way to go well yeah
there was no sorry
adava thunder that way we don't get
suited right away was that greta it was
simply her older brother sister yes my
this look how rosy yeah i'm still in
girls you look jolly
i love campbell's soup or i'm a
dangerous binge drinker i'm not gonna
let you come down my chimney buddy so
please
forget it pal i'm not gonna sit in your
lap so see your chimney i uh 1988 here's
another prediction officials claimed
that uh the maldives would be under
water in the next 30 years so let's see
98 yeah let's count it as an 18. oh wow
oh well that's a that was uh well we're
past it
again truth 30 years later they hit a
record for tourism 1.48
million visitors uh but don't worry
they've revised it now that uh the
maldives could
disappear by the end of the century this
is it's uh csnbc
hey by the way if you guys are watching
right now and you're irritated smash
that like button watching right now on
youtube smash the like button and please
share it with
climate claims because uh
people need to know this stuff because
here's what's funny is you will get
people who rebut this and say you're not
i readily acknowledge i'm not a
scientist this is
the issue here is people buying into
[ __ ] despite them not being a
scientist look if you are not a
scientist isn't it better to start from
the beginning point of skepticism yeah
than it is that accepting it wholesale
you still have people here's what's
ironic you still have some people who
believe these predictions
now i guarantee you if i grab 20 people
off the street a certain number of them
are going to believe the peak oil myths
that have already been moved they don't
know that their scientists have moved
the goal posts right that's the issue
and do you see a pattern here by the way
you're a science niner we talked about
this the other day you're a science
denier you're an election denier you're
you're back to being a science designer
because you're not a virologist right
you're a heretic time this happens get
brow beaten with facts that appear to be
facts well
necessarily i trust the science really
which one oh okay that's why you're
vaccinating five-year-olds
that's messed up that one it really is
yes yeah and now there's kids that have
like like died well what like anyone are
we allowed to say that sorry there's
allegedly there's a let there have
allegedly been some people who may have
had complications at some point
associated with a vaccine even though it
is the safest and most researched with
the best long-term studies yes vaccine
average and the most vaccine sort of
vaccine you can get yes it just makes
common sense yes that's right yes he's a
guy you should trust also the earth is
warming uncontrollably
also sand flies eating a beagle's face
is not gain of science it's just the
natural order of things
functioning gain of functions i watch
species hungry yeah i watch it every
night
before i go to bed sometimes that
happens sometimes i sometimes uh i see a
really attractive woman and when she's a
you know i go are you species you're
species so
it's prediction in 1988 you don't ask
you don't ask that's whole thing with
species you don't know they're like
doesn't tell you she's like she plays
all koi about it like no i'm a woman
you're species yeah they're like
undercover cops yeah like they have to
tell you right
i don't think that's how it works
usually when you see her you know lift a
train car and throw it across a
cornfield you're like species yeah i
knew it i knew it well nothing gets past
me species jump in the sack with you and
you're a disgusting human being yeah
that's enough it should she should if
she doesn't need to throw a train car
she could just say hey you're handsome
i'd be like species do you know by 20 50
33 of all women will be species really
what yeah it's true well hold on a
second no wait a living word
it's going to be uh potentially by the
end of the century oh they moved it
again wait wait wait i'm getting a word
yep update everything that we just said
about species was [ __ ] sorry oh wait
i just got word out last thursday oh my
god what i knew it check your wives i
knew it when my wife choked me with her
forked tongue
i was thinking like that's weird i was
like [ __ ] you species
i knew this [ __ ] you got to tell me
that
wouldn't that be a great film to watch
in a black movie theater in detroit oh
man i love it [ __ ]
there's no way she likes that guy
there's no way he is ugly he is an ugly
mother that [ __ ] is species all right
there you go you gonna die
oh oh [ __ ] now it's kissing species oh
yeah i hope you enjoy that because you
ain't gonna get none you ain't gonna get
none you're just gonna die
from species so
popcorn's burning [ __ ]
all right 1988 prediction
uh bob reese predicted or rice i don't
care predicted that lower manhattan
would be completely underwater by 2018.
uh well here's the thing actually the
truth is no no no no the truth is it
actually has
yeah just not for the reasons they
thought yeah so you know
[Laughter]
i don't know if that's in the archive uh
new york city will be awash in hobo piss
that was the day after tomorrow jake was
like we have to go to the library why
hobo piss
in any constellation it's in much worse
shape it's true might be might be being
underwater would be a great thing for
lower manhattan kind of clean this is
kind of a cleansing of this yeah
yes so uh well here's a good thing
there's an updated uh from travel.com uh
new york city just it'll be underwater
by 2050. oh okay yeah yeah that's a good
thing what wasn't all of miami supposed
to be underwater already there's a whole
bunch of stuff like that it's cocaine it
floats yeah well that's all the
buildings were built on cocaine money
that whole city's coconut i don't know
literally cocaine they just stuff it
under i'm sure a lot of it literally is
what do we do with all this i thought it
was underwater because i needed to cool
the state down from all the mamacitas
oh boy
i agree yeah
look at that
puppy so
i don't know why they said this oh ah
multilingual species
[Music]
it's the googly eye she has to keep
bringing it back because it's trying to
get out
of species yeah she's just back inside
i'm the species exorcist aoc hey species
her people costume is just coming apart
i'm gonna get into a fight over aoc yeah
with the feds or i've been tracking
species for five dragon species for 20
years like get out this is my
jurisdiction like hell
yeah we get that you want us to be
dismantled but uh look this is a real
thing yes
don't give me that i've learned how to
think like species and let me tell you
the species is not exactly what you
think species is an avowed socialist who
drives her tesla three blocks with eyes
googly i repeat googly and she is
stunningly stupid yes uh it's really not
an advance she's just
uncharacteristically dumb yeah just
really
useless mm-hmm but
in congress yes yes we're really doing
it
by letting it they just let it live oh
also by the way you might not want to
let her do jello shots on you because
her tongue will exit your spine so
okay oh next prediction 2010
uh this is actually they said
that their children wouldn't know what
snow is by 2020.
well
i look at texas i don't know what snow
is david parker a researcher at the
hadley
it's mentally impaired
i don't know oh that's what he said he's
like by 2020 all kids will be [ __ ]
different predictions makes more sense
now
i mean
and it was just in arkansas why wouldn't
you i shouldn't
was there's still history
and movies none of this makes
they won't even know what the snow is
everything that's ever captured snow on
film will have been burned by the sun
yes that's the rhetoric like i know what
a woolly mammoth is yeah i i've never
met a triceratops no but i've heard of
them
i've also met a biceratops have you had
sex with anything that moves that i've
never i'm at a quad quad-ceratopsiplegic
well that was one that's not really
that's not really a subspecies it's just
a triceratops who an lsd dove into an
empty pool that's true yeah they do move
in here
so here's a triceratops to speak to the
school about why not to take drugs
here's jeff goldblum reaching into a
spot of [ __ ]
uh all right 2000 children wouldn't know
what snow is but so david parker
researcher at the hadley center for
climate prediction research said british
children
could have only virtual experience wait
is this oh that's right british children
could have only virtual experience of
the snow via the internet they might
wander at polar scenes or eventually
feel virtual cold thank lord we have
this vinyl edition of josh groban's
polar express soundtrack
children
people he was very cold usually
mr scrooge can we blow out all of the
candles making the room so hot yes
because the dark was cheap you'll see an
ebenezer liked it well there i go again
i should i perhaps assume returned back
to my realm of science but it appears
i'm a douche bag there too
so these sweeps are no longer needed
your kids know what snow is i mean
so here's the prediction now in 2040 the
uk won't have snow anymore they didn't
say that children won't know what snow
is but they're like
they won't have it my kid knew what snow
was when we left the hospital
because it was snowing
just ask whiners i only prefer february
snowflakes well you see the problem with
yours he's a climate of denial you see
there are no snowflakes and peanuts land
despite what one mr schultz might try
and indoctrinate you with me
more money please more money please so
always money stupid so much money it's
the biggest racket ever it really
imagine getting paid for making these
predictions imagine getting paid for
saying that in the year 2020 kids won't
know what snow is ah yeah brilliant give
him another ground how much did we pay
for that [ __ ] well thankfully it was in
the uk so we didn't hopefully it was
cheaper i'm sure it's just gonna burn
out one day it will eventually yep and
it's just gonna take this pile of
wastewater in a champagne supernova and
a shampoo
in the sky
2004 here's another prediction
the pentagon reports warned the uk
climate would be like siberia by 2020.
this is from a pentagon report i'm
curious is siberia hot
uh that was also confusing to me because
the previous prediction we had said they
won't know i know snow is yeah that's
this one says they're going to be
covered well this is from the pentagon
so you know what it's different you know
it's uh okay yeah united 93. it's not
just good uh it's pentagon good pentagon
good yes
good pentagon
it puts its pentagram on it yeah it's a
stamp of approval more of a rams head
really what the hell is going on here
it is five points did they cite the
other report on no snow they'd be like
yeah with some building off of this
report you guys are going to be in
apparently the pentagon didn't get the
memo from the scientists who were being
published in the new york times
boy the pentagon really has a shitty
track record doesn't it doesn't even
think about it yeah it does oh gosh so
do scientists yeah apparently i keep
hearing the word consensus but astrology
don't seem to be it doesn't seem to be
so this is from the pentagon report it
was reported in the guardian 2004 they
wrote this major european major european
cities will be sunk beneath rising seas
as britain is plunged into a siberian
climate by 2020. nuclear conflict mega
droughts famine and widespread rioting
will erupt across the world and then
they said not not wait that's that's my
line so
well that's actually true well they got
the right not because of weather yeah it
was it was blm yeah there were droughts
and stuff you see all them dead
flamingos in that picture
super saiyan hey
flamingos can't they fly
you know that i own a flamingo ranch all
right if they can fly it meant no
offense by it it could move you said you
liked my flamingos and i let you feed
them well i lied
i did it i was being polite so in uh
2020 it hurts the uk's
the uk's climate included this is so
stupid that i'm having a fact check this
record-breaking rainfall
record dry and sunny periods and a
summer heat wave but here's the updated
prediction okay update update
we have an update
what
what
no what i don't understand what's
happening me neither do you have a
stroke
update what's the update what are you
talking about i did i said i had a
summer heat wave what what was going on
what are you talking about so there was
an update yeah was that that was it yeah
screw with me is there something going
out to air right now that's like me with
a big dick or something
now that's something you guys would do
you guys all form against me
you're all out you're here to get me did
you guys want to convince everybody i
have a giant penis again
that'll i didn't say attached to me stop
it don't tell people i have a giant
penis again
collect come on come up with something
original come on jeez guys
so why don't you make something up for
me
yeah i pay you to write
not just report
yes
the updated prediction 2021 10 areas of
the uk could be underwater by 2050
because of rising sea levels well okay
well there you go ten areas coming in
areas you said the entire place i don't
fully understand climate i'm not a
scientist i'm just reading
so ten areas sounds like it could be the
whole thing yeah it sounds like it could
be i don't understand how they do it
like states versus provinces well like
but either way someone's missing some
molars well now that rock that's an area
i mean that rock used to be like that
far above the water yeah i mean now it's
gone
i mean i moved it
under the water brew it in the water
that's regardless by the way whenever
people say like well you're not a
scientist yeah also al gore got the
not only did he get the academy award
that's right which gay lesbian was it
was it tonight o'connor was it melissa
etheridge or was it they all sarah
mclaughlin was it the wings of an angel
or was it the current
window
no which lesbian i don't
oh oh for the movie yeah
oh i don't know was it unless richard
was the thing
i don't think it was i don't yeah point
is
al gore and two angry lesbians got
academy awards
he's got some news
step inside eyes on my window
it's warming soon nothing compares to
global warming some inconvenient boobs
oh yes
well no that's 20 20. i love stuff kids
i'm a girl yeah just think about this
for a second you go back to melissa
etheridge the melissa etheridge who won
the 2009 academy award or i don't know
was nominated i'm going by wrote here if
you were to tell melissa etheridge back
then in 2009 be like hey by the way uh
you know that in
in in only 10 years time
you could actually just
put on your driver's license that you're
a man and you can go into the map you
can compete and she's like
don't be a fool now
like so
my career is destroyed yeah yeah you can
really rush it right yeah yeah yeah
so in 2009 this is a prediction al gore
who is also not a scientist but people
weren't complaining when this was being
uh this was actually being taught as a
part of curriculum
you mean the rightful president of the
united states stephen well i won
i won florida i wanted to do a recap
really hold on a second why was there
opposition to the recount
i don't know what counties did you i
only wanted to include three only three
counties
i didn't want to recount the whole state
we're not retired
i won the popular vote i'm a more
popular person right yeah and then that
counts yeah and then people are like
whoa dodge a bullet there
can you imagine him during 9 11 like hi
guys
you have a lot of growing up to do
why would you want to be president after
you've seen what's going on in that
office for the previous eight years well
if we're gonna need a deep cleaning
because he saw what went on in that
office for the previous eight years you
just
break me off a piece of that he said
yeah i'm gonna get some trouble checks
from the mail room disgusting from now
on i have a rule i only hire fat interns
low self-esteem yeah come on in here i
have something for you on a cigar yeah i
know you may be asking how's that a
professional qualification these the
garther that isn't so 2009 he said there
would be no more ice in the arctic by
academy award academy award by
2013. the amount that disappeared in
2005 was equivalent to everything east
of the mississippi the extra amount that
disappeared last fall
was equivalent to this much
comes back in the in the winter
but not as permanent ice
as thin ice
vulnerable you better not stand on it
the amount remaining
could be completely gone in summer in as
little as five years can you imagine him
standing on the ice and it's a wonderful
life that kids are riding on a shovel
just oh these are gonna go straight down
so it's such a knob i know it's like a
dark knight just to be clear the ice
does you know there's ebbing and flowing
so in uh 2012 there was 1.67 million
square miles of arctic ice 2013 2.25
oh mostly true so yeah so yeah oh that's
right so there's more well there was
more but hey they said it was in 2012.
are we going to debunk any of this today
are we just going to make are we the
prosecution well we can't debunk it
because there is an updated prediction
okay
arctic sea ice
could be gone according to national
geographic or as i used to call it the
tube sock titty magazine
uh arctic sea ice could be gone by the
year 2035.
they should have pushed that one out a
little you know come on just having 60
is whatever give yourselves a little
slack yeah it's like in my schedule i
started building in an extra 10 minutes
just for transportation then you'd be
like oh man it happened so much faster
than we thought but we were still right
right um can't do that now uh well
here's the thing though al gore left out
he wanted to focus more on the polar
bears and the ice no
that's sad i mean how is he gonna he
needs how's he gonna set up his home bar
cart you mean those floaty devices that
uh run around and kill things yeah yeah
they drink those soulless machine the
soulless killing machines you mean those
lovely christmas bears that i think
you're being pretty do you have any idea
what would happen to a seal if he showed
up with a coke to a what he deserves
i'd be like trying to say that shield
was making eyes at me
okay so al gore actually you left out an
important aspect of how climate change
affects people and we're not beyond
obviously finding some comment true true
recent study
shows that 70 of americans suffer from
climate anxiety oh wow and here at
louder with crowd we care about people
if nothing else so um we actually asked
people about it and filmed a psa uh
regarding the negative impact of climate
anxiety and how it impacts all of our
lives
you know climate change affects me and
my familia because you know when we were
in guatemala we had to move over here
because we had a big drought
and i lost
five of my siblings and i almost lost
the other one
and so i just
suck okay
i've recently been diagnosed with a very
real condition known as climate anxiety
and unfortunately it's led to a host of
neurological disorders including back
spasms forgetfulness and impotence oh me
uh sorry yeah climate change uh
i'm not really sure if climate change
affects me at all i don't know i don't
know anything about it well here i got
some uh information for you maybe look
this over real quick
i get i guess yeah
climate change affects me because i'm a
veterinarian and in just two years
eighty percent of all animals will be
dead
and i'll be out of a job
but mostly the animal thing
[Music]
so you're saying people are the problem
i have people at home a wife and two
awful stepkids
climate change affects me because my
family has owned a ski resort for over
100 years and now all the snow's melting
and only the tall mountains can stay
open
my hope is through sharing my story that
somebody else out there might be able to
come forward and get treated for this
really
really real thing that is happening
across the world
[Applause]
[Music]
now there's no more climate change in my
house
i'm gonna go to the mall and stop some
climate change there
well look none of us has remained
unaffected it's true what will ski bums
do when they have no mountains yeah
that's true just probably just use new
york city as a public stall
well that's an option i think that man
might have killed his family no i don't
think so oh no i just know he's fighting
climate change no snow snow i wanna piss
my name inside of all the snow
that really is the best part of snow it
is yeah but i've never done it well
enough where people you can't rave well
you know everyone knows that i have now
that you guys started spreading the
rumor
[Laughter]
it's like a firehouse so
um let's just join with our tip yes
so let's uh what's not like
yeah it's more like a wood-burning
which by the way that was a wonderful
toy to give to an eight-year-old dad a
wood burning set ah for crying out loud
i still have heat i still have burn
marks well but did you learn your lesson
i didn't learn anything those things
didn't work things are hard burning sets
yeah okay we had one of those well it
was actually at my grandma's it was a
heater too close to drapes yeah right
yeah there you go it's because you
pushed it there mine was a curling iron
i put inside the foot of my bed by my
dad i don't know what lesson was there
yeah i had a heated blanket yeah in
1985. well my mom would you i actually
have good memories of the heated blanket
my mom would cover there's a lot of
people who don't yeah my mom would cover
me in the electric blanket unfortunately
she'd do it in the tub so yeah
to get that news uh they had a heated
blanket on and burned alive i was like
oh
well it worked
so they were watching the two broads and
final destination in the tanning beds oh
yeah we can't get out all right by the
way hey smash that like button do it
you're watching on youtube and i uh and
and smash uh you can smash the rumble
button too because if we're on youtube
are we still on youtube oh yeah oh good
all right that surprises me yeah i
guarantee you this is going to be
labeled for misinformation even though
they won't have any fact check at all uh
and you guys can uh can comment we're
going to move on to some predictions
that haven't come true yet but are
currently being made or newer
predictions anyway um and i want to hear
what you guys think these are going to
be here's one uh and we'll be talking
about this on mug club dave and i
specifically about michigan because
we're both michiganders yeah uh you know
the lake is very it's important to our
livelihood it is so it's it's really is
kind of at the it's the foundation of
the culture really in michigan
this was in 2013
the prediction was that the great lakes
were going to disappear what we're
seeing in global warming is the
evaporation of our great lakes
it's a scary thing to think about what
this will ultimately do to us
the president is going to face the issue
head-on there are some who want to run
away from it
they can do that if they wish and jackie
treehorn yeah by the way they said that
they would need decades of rain to
restore the levels um decades many many
decades i think that like in 2017 i
believe uh lake huron michigan and
superior set new high water records in
january 2020. hey we did a good job but
they're gone right yeah the previous
records were from the 1980s
and uh we fought the climate change yeah
or sorry sorry wait a second are they do
they all set records i want to make sure
i have that correct i know lake superior
set a record did they all set high water
records in january 2020 i don't know sir
as i know they were all higher than
average and i know superior said very
someone can fact check that's enough to
admonish myself i know lake superior was
a record but uh now ask the guy who
washes my boat
oh the governor's husband yep your boat
that can't go into the overpass because
the water level's too high that's the
thing too they haven't they've had to
redredge harbors all these because
they've made predictions and by the way
this is something else that i've talked
about here you can run a you can run a
search on it or go to lottoscriber.com
you know in michigan cherries are very
important they're big one of the biggest
exports or at least they are the top
exporter of cherries a lot of [ __ ] in
north america yes no and
um cherries the thing about cherries
because now they say well it's not
global warming it's global cooling and
they go well it's it's glow it's extreme
temperatures cherries are a very
persnickety crop they require a long
slow thawing winter and moderate spring
and summer
record cherry crop yield don't worry you
wouldn't know it because the government
fixed the price they fixed the prices so
they don't they dump cherries when
there's a surplus so we have homeless
people couldn't you just get couldn't
you just give them all of the milk that
we dump and the cherries i mean you need
to have some extra bathrooms open but
the point is we don't have to be there
if you're starving let them eat cherries
let them eat cherries and let them drink
milk there you go milk and cherries i
was in that movie
yeah it was lake huron michigan and
superior that set records it set records
okay wow they really did wow huh i was
reading uh i was reading some mish i
guess m live is full of crap
you can't trust i was reading a local uh
president what i read said that superior
said a record but that michigan didn't
so it's eerie it's all of them well
huron
michigan superior yeah so erie and the
others were higher than average
who cares the point is uh the starfish
are [ __ ] because that's the point
another literally that's the next one
yeah start this is another prediction
it's made in 2017. you guys all heard
about this because we had to talk about
in the show that uh uh um wasting
starfish disease is caused by
aids climate change
scientists are searching for clues to
what's been killing starfish and what is
killing sea stars in some places 95 of
the starfish population has died
so much
syndrome and it causes the marine
animals to die in a particularly
gruesome way and as the tissue dies they
oftentimes will lose arms out in college
all i did was kill starfish disintegrate
the arms just crawl away okay
but that arm's like i'm out of here not
if pete butt cake has anything to say
about it get over here
he's like he's like scorpion
so
oh my lord as recently as this year
and going back to 2013 the die-off was
attributed to climate change by outlets
like the new york times the independent
and of course they cited scientists
however actually oops
uh now uh empiricists at cornell i don't
know if you know this but uh keith
auburn went there did he they went to
cornell
you could only be
so fortunate as to fervently study in
the ways of douche baggery so everyone
here is related
so
they at cornell trace a smoking gun to
an actual to a virus the denso virus
actually so it's not climate change it's
an actual virus here you go after months
of research scientists have identified
the pathogen at the heart of the
starfish wasting disease they say it's
different from all other known viruses
infecting marine organisms they've
dubbed it sea star associated densovirus
when you look on a scale of hundreds and
hundreds of animals as we did it's very
clear that the virus is associated with
symptomatic sea stars okay
did i just see a purple starfish
dreams do come true said pete butt kick
sorry his
husband i mean i did that i used to have
to get a balloon and stretch it so
whenever i see purple starfish i get an
ice pack
and here's the thing where people will
say oh that's not the number one concern
no it's not but this is what they use to
manipulate children i know when i was a
kid and i watched captain planet they
had certain myths that they would
perpetuate for children this is what
they want to do we all know that we grew
up we kids
kids in this generation the starfish
probably their polar bears you remember
us it was the polar bears that's what we
were all polar bears absolutely there'd
be no more polar bears which i was like
i don't really give a [ __ ] you know i
mean at a certain point i don't really
care again i've never met one it's the
same thing they always complain like oh
what if we lose all the great whites but
fine you know i don't think any i don't
think any surfers are like remember the
good old days no no when you were
missing half your hamstring no no no
i'll take my chances with a few extra
sunfish
yeah there's no one-legged surfer that's
like let's save those things yeah let's
save those
let's save those souls just like the
people in that uh whatever power plant
in the thing you know they'd still
rather take their chances with the
shapeshifter than going out with the
polar bears i'm sure they would love it
if it got a little warmer there yeah for
crying out loud anyway this is this
brings us to our next prediction that we
all grew up with so you have the
empirical you have the scientific
studies that are incorrect and then
these are the ones that they use to tug
on your heart strings like leo dicaprio
oh we had to tape the revenant in uh uh
ecuador or some [ __ ] i don't know i
couldn't stop focusing on his man-bun
so he needs some real shock therapy can
someone put him on a
rotating chair and dip him back into an
electrical pool like shutter island i
don't like can you method act that
okay it really should be cut off yeah
and handed to him like this is dead now
this is the prediction uh in 2020 now
they've revised it because i mean this
prediction a bunch of times that the
polar bear species is headed for
extinction oh no arctic polar bears are
facing near extinction
if the sea ice they depend on uh
continues to disappear a stark warning
from a new study looking at the
long-term future of the bears as
greenhouse gas emissions contribute to
the melting of the bears frozen hunting
grounds
what is that slush thing they they put
that they they put that polar bear in
the middle of the photo shoot in the
middle of brooklyn i like that the polar
bear is just staring over like what this
is what i do i'll kill you too yeah you
want to dance boy you look edible
you know what happens if the polar bears
run out of food
where they currently are
they i don't actually dave of course
they just sit there and die because they
have no intellect they don't have the
ability to go somewhere they go
somewhere else to get more food yeah
they don't have a mcdonald's for polar
bears well the point is that's where we
need to build the wall is to stop the
polar bears from coming over they're
heading south boys that's really
dangerous yeah we're saying you could
eat them oh my gosh you're gonna need it
sounds like a horrible pixar movie it
sounds like a horrible no more like
dream works like well the polar bears
are headed south like a polar bear and a
whole glass surfboard
hey come on watch your old man dead and
the mom's like oh shake what your mother
gave you i'm going to kind of sent in
why do all the other bears say we're
privileged here
the black bears
yes chris rock as a black bear the
problem with polar bears is you are into
running and [ __ ] what this isn't
child appropriate no not at all see this
polar bears and that that there is
grizzly bears and there's kodiaks
people love a grizzly bear but ain't
nobody got time for a kodiak
all right dreamworks
i will sue you get on with that no get
on it
we need to write that movie
call it south for the win at some point
there's gonna be a dance montage to i
like to move it move it you know that
shit's gonna yeah
yeah they'll dig up a couple that's one
thing i'm not sure here or two of my
children the what the crap that i love
to watch enjoy i can give you a list of
good ones there are some good ones yeah
well you got to go back look everything
made by them is not it by hollywood is
not awful no no no no there's some good
stuff in there where
i well you challenge them
have a horrible taste but i i mean other
than wine i'm sure you're good there but
uh other than that
oh i know
he's lucky he's married for a while who
can decorate his house i think pick up
his clothes yeah
i did apparently no he touches them okay
so the prediction that the polar bears
were going to be extinct let me extinct
let me clarify something now
i i've talked about this before that
there have been more polar bears on
record there have been polar bears
increasing significantly and actually uh
philip mccleary and ann mcelini have
talked about this uh but i also
understand the counter-argument before
you make it that methodology has changed
and they didn't really have an accurate
head count but the point is they're
certainly nowhere near being extinct now
the point that i would like to address
here is the prediction that they were
going to be extinct it stems from this
idea that the species this is important
appeared about 100 000 years ago yeah
okay
and uh that was around the last ice age
and that they wouldn't survive the
warming projections well here's the
thing though now scientists say that the
species is 500
500 000 years old to simplify it that
means that polar bears as a species have
survived warming periods that were more
severe for longer sustained amounts of
time ah
really yeah they've been four four
warmer than now cycles within that time
frame just to be clear
what why don't by the way if they
weren't around at one point potentially
one quick thing what is clip j there
quarter black yard i have no idea
uh it's a greta oh okay all right all
right so
so if they came about let's say they
came about a hundred thousand five
hundred whatever just for argument's
sake a hundred thousand years ago and
we're like oh we have to do something to
protect them well they weren't here
before and things seemed i guess fine
the neighborhood was cool then yeah
really we have to make sure they stay
yeah animals do come and go until we get
involved yeah absolutely it was like
those stupid canadian geese where we're
like let's save those from extinction
and they're everywhere and they're
[ __ ] they're the worst
airplanes yeah they attack you
they attack you and they poop like they
poop and they know what they're doing
like
yeah you think
ah
shouldn't have been shouldn't have uh
brought a bunch of us into the apartment
complex fake pond that sully loves him
though he's like no he loves him because
he's like that's how everybody knows me
thanks to them geese
i think he steered into him
he probably did he's like i can get this
hold on damn geese yeah
he
was trying to hit and run geeks yeah no
he was trying to splat him he's like hey
i think i can get them gooses one two
three four five yeah
geese gotta buy score oh oh no oh we
lost both engines so like i hate geeses
to pieces
it's usually though it is true we've
done this so many times with species
yeah but it's almost like it's nature
like basically we've been beating pandas
into having sex with each other for the
last 15 years like we want to go extinct
yeah they don't even want to it's like
just have sex with the other one yeah
we're giving them like black and white
sex contraptions like hey look look like
the pen is sitting there
is a half and half and i don't care for
it okay and welcome at my dinner table
lighting aromatherapy candles we got
from body shops no offense qb what
pandas what you're too good to [ __ ]
oh go in the hole are you too good for
the whole
go in your home
oh my gosh seriously anderson pandas
just want to eat bamboo yeah they just
want better eyes pandas need pandas need
their own little uh species to
appreciate what they've got that's true
they do that's true
but if that mini ice age comes what are
they gonna do now i don't even know that
it affects them i don't know either
apparently bamboo is really sustainable
which by the way i think bamboo is
mostly [ __ ] just to be clear hold on
a second it can be bed sheets it can be
wooden textiles and you can eat it in
your thai curry nope it can
don't believe it i don't buy it i don't
buy it it's like the peanuts well you
tell me that when you turned collard
greens into a nice throw rug
so
uh after bringing down all of these
failed predictions i think that we've
all come to a conclusion naturally you
can shove your climate crisis up your
arse
you can shove your climate crisis off
your arms
if you can shove your climate crisis you
can shove your climate crisis you can
shut your
you know i agree i couldn't have said it
better i don't know why she sees kids
songs though
i don't know
could be a correlation i have a guess
but i'm not allowed to say it she's
gonna do itsy bitsy spider next yeah
yeah i have no idea
climate change went up the people spout
down came acid rain and kill all the
people out
oh so sad i usually say down came the
hobo piss and washed the new york city
out
dicaprio
that's honestly how you know your city
sucks when hobo piss is cleansing i live
there there's nothing shocking about
that photo no no that's just where their
bathroom is hobo's pissing in your
streets in manhattan is basically an
herbal essences commercial for yeah the
real problem is camera phones uh in
general because that would have been
taken care of by a simple nudge of a
it's cab in the good old days that's the
problem now hey bird scooters don't have
enough velocity exactly
because really yeah well it's less it's
a hobo kid but you know we can take him
out anymore well no yeah you're right it
could be a hobo kid i don't need a
scooter for that singing about
pickpocketing it's a good push kick you
could come on getting a hobo kid yeah
got to pick a pocket or two
we've got a piss in a street or two
extra extra read all about hey this is
yesterday's newspaper we already have
your twenty get him
all right bait him to death in the
street yeah ah listen sir i'm just uh
i'm just homeless pickpocket trying to
sell me papers you just say you were a
pickpocket boy i said paper salesman
today i pushed a dandy man in front of
the subway train yeah but it was his
fault he was pissing on the third round
he was
less carbon when i when i went to push
him away i gave myself a shock
ronald fell in
all right so look we're gonna uh by the
way i want you to comment you guys can
let us know what prediction do you think
has been the most pernicious all
references all sources available at
light with credit.com there's a lot to
comb through um and i want to be clear
that uh look we're not this isn't
falling on deaf ears obviously there are
two sides to every issue
um and as you know that youtube has
really they've really been they've
really been on our buttocks lately a
little bit so we're actually going to
start incorporating at least one
progressive segment into every show okay
to uh diversify
like fair time the wonderful programming
that this is so before we'll go to mug
club but actually uh
uh dave and i are going to be talking
about michigan specifically but before
that for youtube to appease them i want
you to uh please you to enjoy this
latest installment of climate changers
[Music]
whoa
where did you guys come from that's not
important right now but what is
important is what you can do to stop
climate change what i can do yep even
you
i noticed you had your ac running
mind if we take a look listen guys i
know climate change is really important
but my apartment gets really hot this
time of year i just can't turn it down
down
i want you to make it colder
make it colder
look here it's only set to 68 but let's
go lower
there we go 54. now it's really pumping
now let's get these windows open
i don't think this is really helping
because now it's all just going outside
exactly it's going back outside into the
climate
whoa
you're right yeah now check this out
normally 99 of air conditioning is
trapped inside buildings and wasted when
absorbed by humans and walls
but instead if we simply opened our
windows the ac would still cool us a
little bit and the rest would go outside
to slightly lower the temperature of the
air
wow that's amazing although i do feel
pretty selfish for hogging air
conditioning to myself
that's okay as long as you're learning
that's what really matters well this is
really great to know and all but i just
can't help but wonder if it's making any
difference well
just because you can't feel the
temperature change over time doesn't
mean it's not happening just like the
hamburger man who is a hamburger man it
makes a difference
as of right now the world has 1.9
billion air conditioning units on our
own it may seem like we can't make that
big of a difference but just think if we
all listened to science and cranked up
that ac
you know what i've got a few more
windows in my bedroom we can open right
now
[Music]
54 better make that 52.
[Music]
now you got it
science changes
[Music]
i